[Music]
Family Feud that's funny let's play all
right can we get a timer with 60 seconds
on the clock name a house you never want
to be
in uh haunted house name something
associated with
vampires blood name something in a
person's closet that only comes out on
special occasions
tuxedo tell me a word that rhymes with
election
erection wow what's something you keep
that's the only word that rhymes with
that what's something you keep in your
car just in
case a gun erection what what did you
say erection erection that's I think
we're supposed to do 30 seconds but that
that was that was question yeah that was
way too much what rhymes with election
that's the only thing what do you mean
erection yeah def connection any any
shun what did you think of
selection that was the you didn't think
of erection no dude it's one letter off
so so selection you add in
this yeah I guess Obie how many points
did he
get she's adding them up 114 hey wait so
go through do you have like yeah I have
the list for the first question what did
you
say 27 points number one answer that was
the number one answer okay number two uh
what did you say blood zero points oh no
sorry got 29 Points I saw blood sucker
29 Points was that the top answer was
Twilight top answer was Twilight whoa
that's crazy uh the next question was
named something in a person's closet
that can only that only comes out on
special occasions you said tuxedo that
was the number one answer 35
points uh tell me a word that rhymes
with election you said erection please
tell me that's on the [__] list
number two answer 23 points really yeah
what's one selection was number one
what's something you keep in your car
just in case what did you say I said gun
gun uh yeah no zero zero points on that
one what's dude if we were in the city
where the [__] where that guy's from
the you can call me anything you want I
guarantee he has a gun in his car
guaranteed what were the answers for
that uh the number one answer was money
coins you want to play I have coins I
just throw them in the
garbage
no I'm
kidding go to Cody's house garbage can
full of coins yeah you want hear change
yes please smells so bad in here yeah
that's the trash it's all my [__]
money line around Co all right next
we'll do one more 30 seconds on the
clock starts after I read the first
question name an occasion for which you
might wear your lucky
underwear date name something you do if
the person sitting sitting next to you
on an airplane had bo jack
off name something a woman with a crush
on Santa might leave out for him instead
of
cookies her panties name something that
might be full of
holes a
glory come on one more other than
letters named something people get in
the mail Jack I'm off jacking
off you said name an occasion uh for
which you might wear your lucky
underwear you set a date right yep
number one answer 30 points d d ding
ding ding name something youd do if the
person sitting next to you had an
airplane had a airplane had
bo you said jack off uh survey said zero
no one okay come on okay zero really no
that's not on there no one no one said
so then what do you guys do well the
number one answer was change seats what
oh name something woman with a crush on
Santa might leave out for him instead of
cookies you said panties survey said
lingerie with 14 points ding ding ding
ding ding number one no no number one
was candy or better food what wait oh I
thought number one was going to be a uh
like a jar of her
farts something that might be full of
holes you said Glory yeah glor a glory
hole uh yeah Z yeah zero okay Swiss
cheese was number one a good answer so
for those playing along at home I should
have said yeah I should have said a
bathroom a truck stop bathroom
wall yeah that was number one with 60
yeah yeah uh other than letters named
something people get in the mail I
believe you also said jacking
off no points awarded okay [__] one more
name something you buy after you get a
puppy
kennel name something you might find in
a
kitchen Fork
name something you might do right before
you go to bed jack
off name a food that children do not
like to
eat
vegetables more
specific green
vegetables
salad come on Obie oh name something you
wear on your head wear in your head on
your head headphones hat wow that's got
to take your first answer headphones
[__] hat you want your answers yeah I
think you got no
points
okay there's no way that jacking off
that time was not the right
answer I'm not sure okay that's like in
everyone's nighttime
routine
right right guys no I'm kidding right
okay name something you buy after you
get a puppy
kennel that is the number what the
number one is food okay but what are the
other ones toys collar leash bed okay
yeah good luck potty training it then
[__] you're going to have a dog that
plays a lot but shits all over your
[__] house if you don't have a kenel
I guess we can say bed is the same and
get you have four points then it's not
the it's not the same but okay you have
no points continue name something you
might find in a kitchen you said
Fork number one answer is refrigerator I
just wrote into chat GPT make up a
Family Feud Fast Money round tailored
for Cody Co oh okay I like this you
ready well yeah I want to hear oh sorry
sorry I thought we were done
Jus um dishes might count for four so
that would be 11 points okay name
something you do right before you go to
bed number one answer shower or bath
name of food that children do not like
to eat I think you said vegetables I
said green vegetables then green
vegetable you and
salad the number and answer is fish huh
two is brussels sprouts fish sticks is
like a little kid food yeah three is
broccoli four is eggs five is avocados
eggs okay final question n name
something n
n what places places most likely to nare
what were the what was the okay number
one was a hat or cap or bonnet number
two a
helmet it's in the name dude it head
headphones number three a headband I
mean it's better than [__] Bonnet who
wears a bonnet nowadays a girl yeah
probably a girl probably a girl watching
[__] Twilight
Twilight what was the last answer number
four was Veil or
scarf and then five was wig I'm pretty
sure there's more people out outside
right now wearing headphones then a
[__] Veil
right all right what so what's
yours all right uh here we go name
something you'd find in a YouTuber's
setup a camera what's a word people
often associate with Cody
Co um
old name a place where Cody Co might go
to film content his office name a common
subject Cody Co makes videos about mil
man
what is a what is a who is a
collaborator Cody Co often works with
Noel uh all right so camera was the
number one answer uh what word did you
say people oh yeah no the number one was
comedy there's also Vine YouTuber tiny
meat gang and
podcast nope okay name a place where
Cody Co might go to film content uh
office was not on there but Studio
Street Beach coffee shop or home Studio
I do film in coffee shops pretty
often dude you'll catch me vlogging in a
Starbucks all the time you know Common
subject Cody Co makes videos about the
top answers were reaction videos
internet Trends music comedy sketches
and social media okay I mean that's just
yeah and then too vague you got the
number one answer for the collaborator
Noel Noel Miller what were the other
ones Kelsey kple Jake Paul in a
confrontational context Spock and post
Malone wow is this GB four or three four
really yeah I feel like it should be
more like updated than that huh
interesting doesn't quite know Cody CO's
full discography yeah yeah you should uh
look into what I've been doing recently
chat jbt all right that's a pretty dated
version of what I've been
[Music]
doing